the two people I'm a huge fan of from
that time in Mad TV's Bobby League he
plays Skyrim he's a huge fan he plays
every so what Bobby Lee loves to do
is the grind do the boring task over and
over gather mushroom like in Skyrim you
can fight dragons you can fight all
kinds of things but you can also gather
mushrooms and different ingredients to
make potions and all that kind of he
loves the ingredients that he's the you
know in the hunter-gatherer World he's
together he's The Gatherer yeah I've
heard him described that way and and he
likes to describe himself that way uh I
worked with Bobby not too long ago he
came and did a couple days on this thing
we were shooting and uh I was looking
forward to catching up with my old pal
and if you know anything about Bobby Lee
you'd probably be able to predict that
he spent that entire time playing
farming on his iPad all humans are a
source of anxiety and trouble so
sometimes it's good to escape human
interaction through video games totally
I'm with him on that he's he's one of
the funniest people ever what what do
you think is uh what do you think makes
him funny it's just all the times you've
worked with him the the
non-standard non-secular way of his
being
Bobby Lee is one of the most Raw people
raw performers who lets it all hang out
to the degree that he will even get
naked in front of his audience which is
usually a metaphor for someone doing
stand up I'm bearing all yeah I'm
showing you everything and Bobby will
just uh pull his bird out of his pants
yeah I don't think he understands
metaphor too much he embodies metaphor
yes he embodies metaphor he's The Gather
we call him the Gathering metaphor Bobby
The Gatherer metaphor he's a metaphor
for something else for somebody else's
life someday he'll be in the dictionary
yeah representing some kind of concept
maybe the metaphor itself yeah once once
this whole thing falls apart and we are
climbing the Kudzu Vines uh that spiral
up the Sears Tower like they say in
Fight Club Bobby will go back to his
gatherer form and be happy as a pig and
[ __ ] just walking around in a loin cloth
with his bird hanging out tracking jokes
to people and climbing up on them for a
stool lap dance